- [Tutor] Let's talk about one
of the most fundamental ideas
in science and that is
the notion of energy
and energy definitely has some
meaning in our everyday life,
if we kind of imagine
things that are moving
or hot or bright as being energetic,
but what I wanna talk about in this video
is a more formal definition of it,
a more scientific definition
and the most typical one,
that's often given is
the ability to do work,
ability to do and I'm
gonna put work in quotes,
because the notion of work here
isn't the everyday notion of
work, where you go to your job
and you work nine to
five and you get paid,
work in a physics context is a little bit,
it's not completely unrelated
to our everyday notion of work,
but I'll give you an example
just to get a better idea of it,
so let's say that you
have some object here
and you were to apply a force,
you were to apply a
force in that direction
and the magnitude of that
force, let's say it's 10 newtons
and if the units, newtons in force
isn't too familiar to
you, don't worry too much,
but you can also review it on
those videos on Khan Academy,
but you apply a force to
the right on this object
and by doing that you're
able to move the object,
you're able to displace the object
in the same direction as that force,
so you're able to displace
it, let's say 10 meters,
so after you've done it, the object,
the object is right over here,
so when you do this, you apply a force
and it's causing the
object to be displaced
in the direction of that force,
you would say that work has been performed
and the amount of work
that has been performed
would be 10 newtons times 10 meters
and so 10 times 10, it
would be equal to 100
and then the units are
newton meters of work,
100 newton meters,
'cause you're multiplying
newtons times meters
of newton meters of
work and newton meters,
that has been defined as the joule,
which is the unit of work
and also the unit of energy,
so this is the same thing as 100,
I could write it out as joules, 100 joules
or we could just abbreviate it with a J,
so 100 joules of work
has been performed here
by moving this, so we've
done something here
and this is considered to
be work, 100 joules of work,
if we move this twice as far,
then it would be 200 joules of work
and so energy is the ability
to do this type of work.
Now let's look at these pictures here,
which are depicting
different forms of energy
and let's see if we can
identify the forms of energy
and then think about how they can relate
to actually doing work.
So if we look at the fire here,
there's some maybe
obvious forms of energy,
we have some thermal energy,
fires are definitely
hot, so thermal energy,
but we should think about
what is thermal energy fundamentally?
A system's temperature is really about
the average kinetic
energy of its molecules,
so thermal energy is really
about the energy of movement,
it's really about all these
little molecules here,
because of the combustion
reaction going on,
they're getting excited and
they have higher kinetic energy
and so the temperature goes up,
their average kinetic energy goes up,
so thermal energy is really a
form of energy due to movement
and the general term for
energy due to movement
is kinetic energy, so thermal
energy is really a form
of kinetic, kinetic,
kinetic energy.
You also have light being emitted,
that has energy as well, we
call that radiant energy,
so that light being emitted,
that's the reason why
we can see this fire,
radiant, radiant energy.
Now you might say,
"Okay, maybe that's all of
the energy in the system,"
but I'll say no, there's
another form of energy
and actually even in this picture,
that's probably where
most of the energy is
and that's potential energy,
so where is the potential energy?
Well, it's sitting in the
bonds of the fuel over here,
so these are either chips of
wood or charcoal of some kind,
but these are formed
by carbon-carbon bonds,
so you have these carbon-carbon bonds
and they could be bonded to other carbons
or other things and they're
also going to be bound
to some hydrogens here and there,
so you're gonna have, you're
gonna have bonds like this,
that actually store energy in them,
they have the potential to be released,
if you're able to break these bonds,
those electrons are gonna get
into a lower energy state,
or they might bond with other
things and in the process,
they're going to release energy,
that's gonna be radiant energy
and thermal/kinetic energy,
so how does this happen?
How do these bonds actually get broken?
Well, that's our good old
friend, the combustion reaction,
that's our good old friend,
the combustion reaction,
where you take some oxygen,
you take some heat or we
could say some energy,
so it takes a little
energy to get started,
that's why you might have to light this
with a match to begin with,
so oxygen plus energy,
plus energy
and then you could say plus
these carbon-carbon bonds
and you could say plus
you know, whatever it is,
these fuels, which are made out of carbon,
either charcoal or wood, so
plus, I'll do it like this,
I'll draw some carbon-carbon
bond right over here,
that's going to combust and
I'll do this in a color,
so that is going to,
I'm really having trouble changing colors,
this is going to combust,
combust
and it's going to release,
it's going to release
water, because the fuel
has hydrogens in it,
it's going to release carbon dioxide
and it's going to release
a lot more energy,
I'll do that in caps,
it's going to release a lot more energy
and that energy we see in the form
of the kinetic energy of the molecules
and the radiant energy being emitted.
Now you might say, "Okay, I can buy that,
"I have this potential energy here,"
and this potential energy
that's in the bonds between these atoms,
we call that chemical potential,
so we have chemical,
chemical potential energy,
potential, potential energy
is right over there, but you
might say, "Okay, I buy that,
"the chemical energy is being converted
"into the thermal energy
and the radiant energy,"
and this is actually an interesting point,
energy, this is the law
of conservation of energy,
energy cannot be created or destroyed,
it can only be converted
from one form or another,
but you might be saying,
"Okay, I can convert
from one form to another,
"but how can this actually do work
"in the way that I've even depicted here?"
Well, the entire Industrial Revolution
is all about trying to convert
from one form of energy
to another and also to do work,
so a steam engine is fundamentally
based upon combustion,
heating up some steam and
then that steam can expand
and then it can push a piston
to do all sorts of things,
including move a train,
combustion is what's going
on in your car engines,
where the pistons are expanding
due to the thermal energy
and then that helps drive the drive train
of the actual car, so
it can clearly do work.
So here we have some other
examples, this is lightning
and so when you see the lightning,
there's something clearly
very kinetic is going on,
you have electrons, you have electrons
moving from the cloud, from
the cloud to the ground
and you might say, so
this right over here,
that is, you could say
that's kinetic energy,
kinetic, kinetic energy and you might say,
"Well, how can I do work with that?"
Well, that's what the
whole electronics industry
is all about, that's what
power lines are all about,
movement of electrons, that's current
and current can be used to do
all sorts of amazing things,
you can actually have an electric motor
is one way to actually do it,
so that's kinetic energy there,
there's clearly radiant energy going on,
we can see the lightning and
that radiant energies do,
because the air gets
ionized and gets heated
and so there's also thermal energy,
as the electrons go down,
there's heat that is
actually being generated.
Now, where did this energy come from?
It just doesn't come from anywhere,
well, you have all of
this potential energy,
that starts building up in these clouds
as the water vapor rises and the mechanism
isn't fully understood
of how this happens,
but because of energy from the sun,
you have water vapor rising,
as the water vapor rises
through the clouds,
the bottom part of the
cloud becomes more negative,
it becomes more electron rich
and the top part of the
cloud become more positive
and so you have these electrons,
that really wanna get
down here onto the ground,
because the air above the
ground becomes more negative,
the ground starts becoming more positive
and so you can imagine these electrons,
more and more wanna get down here,
but this air isn't a natural conductor,
but once the electric
potential gets high enough,
these electrons find a way, the
air essentially gets ionized
and the electrons are able to find a path,
so while this is all building up,
you have this electrostatic
potential building,
so this is electrostatic,
static, you can't see it that well,
electrostatic potential
and how this forms,
once again, it's an area
that people are still,
there's some good theories out
there about how this forms,
but it's not 100% well established
and over here in this third old drawing
of this person doing a handstand dive,
this is probably the most typical example
of potential energy being
converted into kinetic energy
that you might find in a physics textbook.
Over here at the top of the diving board,
this gentleman has potential energy
by virtue of his position and over here,
it's very clear he has
the potential to fall
and it has the potential to
turn it into kinetic energy
and so once he falls over, at this point,
most of his potential energy
has been converted into kinetic energy,
so here it's potential,
here it's potential
and here it is kinetic,
kinetic energy.
So the big takeaway is energy
has the ability to do work,
it cannot be created or destroyed,
but it can be converted
from one form to another
and all of the forms at their essence,
you can really think about
them in two big buckets,
you can think about
them as potential energy
or kinetic energy,
or kinetic energy
and as a last example, you might say,
"Well, how can this guy do work?"
Well, you can imagine if there
was some type of system here,
new system here, where, you know,
we'll create some machinery,
maybe there's a pulley right over here
and then it's lifting a
weight right over here,
well, if he jumped on this,
he won't fall down as fast,
but then if, as long as he's
heavier than this weight,
it's gonna pull this down
and then this weight is gonna go up,
so he has the potential to do work
by virtue of his position,
there just isn't this pulley system there
to get that actual work done.